sledgehammer games co-founder Glenn
Schofield is talking at the studio's
latest project the 2014 edition of call
of duty saying that it is both ambitious
and creative I'm mark Walton and welcome
to another gamespot news update speaking
at a game developers conference
presentation in San Francisco scholfield
said this year's call of duty will be
the most ambitious most creative game
we've ever made referring to his
development career alongside other
sledgehammer games co-founder Michael
condrey scholfield and Condrey have
worked together for many years now and
are perhaps best known for helping
create the Dead Space franchise that
visceral games for Electronic Arts
Activision hired Schofield an Condrey in
2009 to lead sledgehammer games the
studio's first project was called a duty
modern warfare 3 the [ __ ] co-developed
with Infinity Ward sledgehammer games
now has around 200 people on staff which
makes the studio one of the biggest in
Northern California Schofield said the
call of duty series is now on a
three-year three studio development
cycle previously the franchise was
developed on a two year interval with
Infinity Ward launching games during
odd-numbered years and Trey off
releasing titles during even-numbered
years now sledgehammer games is in the
mix as well as supporting Studios raven
software and neversoft entertainment
Activision maintains that this move will
allow developers to have extra time to
not only create new features to help
push the brand forward but also so they
can spend more time polishing each game
installment in the call of duty
franchise will still be released on a
yearly basis so what do you think what
will sledgehammer games bring to the
call of duty franchise let us know in
the comments below and keep it gamespot
for all your video game news